-This was obviously
an incredibly close cast.
You guys got along very well
yes?
-Yes.
-Is that safe to say?
-Yeah.
-Is it nice to kind of --
I mean, obviously, you hav
a premiere,
you do a little bit of
press together.
Is it nice to see everybod
again?
-It's so nice.
I mean, you know, we've all kept
in touch
since we finished the film
and it kind of doesn't feel like
it's been a year
since we finished.
But we've all gone off
and done other things.
Emma's been sort of
saving the world.
And Flo has been really busy
working,
and Eliza's on Broadway.
-And you've been
Christmas shopping.
-I've been --
[ Laughter ]
I've been on Amazon, just
getting my little gifts.
You know, decorating the tree.
So we're all serving society
-Everybody's kind of evenl
successful for the past -- yeah.
-Yeah, I feel -- I feel so
And Meryl's, you know -- but
yeah, we all get on really well,
and it's just been so nice
to get back together.
-You had a couple of roommates
in the cast, right?
Florence and Eliza.
You guys, you basically
lived together
over the course of the shooting?
-Well, we lived in this little
sort of complex
in a place called Bedford
in Massachusetts.
And we were the old--
or we were the youngest people
probably by about like 30 year
I would say.
Everyone was very --
was very old there.
[ Laughter ]
Which I prefer being aroun
much, much older people,
or very, very young people
so it was nice.
We sort of bonded
because of that.
We only really had each other.
-Were the old people
happy to have you around?
Were they as happy to have you
No. Yeah.
-But I mean, we're not
like mads, you know?
We're not like
some 20-year-olds
where we're out all night,
playing music, you know.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not, as you can tell
by my finger guns.
-The very way you did that
yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Even if you had said, "We're the
kind of people that play music,"
I would have been like,
"No, you're not."
[ Laughter ]
-You're really not.
-You've given yourself away with
your light finger gunning.
-I play a bit of Stevie Nicks.
You know?
-See, that's right in the --
I mean, Stevie Nicks
is the wheelhouse of the peopl
that were living in
that complex.
They should have been thrilled
to have you around.
-Yeah, I think
they would have been.
Maybe if it was just me, but
maybe Eliza and Florence sort --
-They spooked them.
-They sabotaged any chance
I had of becoming friends
with these people.
-Yeah, exactly.
We talked -- when Timothee
your co-star Timothee Chalamet
was here,
he talked about dance lessons,
'cause there's dancing
in the film.
-Yeah.
-And Greta, the fantastic
director of the film,
gave you guys dance --
Was that fun for you?
Do you fashion yourself
much of a dancer?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, yes.
I don't know why you had to as
me that. It's pretty obvious
I like to think that I'm a great
dancer when I've had a few
-Yeah.
-But, when -- you know,
in the daytime, I come to
the very sober realization tha
I'm probably not a great dancer.
I kind of look like a muppet
dancing I think.
I'm all -- my friends always say
that I'm all arms.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very sort of, like, bendy.
Tim is actually
a really good dancer,
and I think he did ballet
for a while as well, so he's -
-He had a leg up on you.
-Yeah.
-But I was very good at sticking
to the steps, and he would try
and change it and I was like
"No, no.
Let's follow the rules."
[ Laughter ]
And we'll have fun within that
-Yeah.
-Structure.
-Yeah, no free styling.
-No.
-You have a --
There's a traumatic scene
where your character Jo
cuts her hair.
-Yes.
-And then you have to
wear a wig.
-I do.
-And this is lovely.
One of your co-stars
helped you --
-We named her.
-You named the wig?
-We named the wig.
-Okay, and what was
the wig's name?
-Pam.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Her name was Pam.
She was from Perth in Australia.
This is a terrible
Australian accent.
-Oh, my goodness.
-To any Australians, I'm sorry
-So Pam had a backstory
and, like, an accent?
-Yeah. So, like, I have this
other beautiful wig,
and it's very long
and sort of luscious.
And this wig
is equally brilliant.
I mean, what we wanted to do -
because, you know, sometimes
when characters --
-This is Pam here?
-That's Pam.
-Yeah.
-That's me, and that's Pam
-Yeah, okay. Gotcha.
Don't make -- Can this --
I'm sorry.
Can this just be about Pam
I know that's you, but can w
just give her a little --
-Alright.
-Okay, fine.
-But I mean you have me
on the show.
-Yeah.
-In that case,
bring Pam on to the show.
-Yeah.
-Alright?
-We tried to book Pam and we
heard from your people
that she was not allowed
to come on.
-Wow. Pam's back in Perth
right now, on Trip Advisor
We had this thing where we wer
like, she's the kind of person
that would, like, put bad
reviews up online of like B&Bs
that she had stayed in
and probably like carries around
a clipboard
just for the hell of it.
Like, she's one of those.
-She's a very like, sort o
a vicious wig, it sounds like.
-Yeah, she's just got
a lot of opinions. You know?
-You're very good with accents
Did people tell you you ha
a bad Australian accent?
-Eliza tells me all the time
that I've got
a bad Australian accent,
and Margot Robbie tells me
that I've got
a bad Australian accent.
-Can we hear it again
real quick?
-[ Australian accent ] I mean,
what do you want me to say
You know, I'm Pam.
I'm Pam,
and I'm here to entertain.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's pretty good.
It's pretty good.
-[ Normal voice ] It's not
Thank God Eliza is on stag
right now.
Otherwise she would be
so embarrassed.
-Thank you.
Please do give
all of our best to Pam.
-I will. She was asking for you,
all of you.
-All of us.
-She really wants everyone
to go see "Little Women."
-That's great.
-On Christmas Day.
-Thanks so much for being here
-Thanks, Seth.
-It's always such a lovely -
lovely to have you here.
Saoirse Ronan, everybody.